ouais comment ça va bien
tiens la femme qui arrive je vous aurais
tout à l'heure dans mon bureau bien
monsieur ministre hantée jolie alors
c'est pas super jeunes comme style mais
c'est joli
partageant team j'ai un vrai métier moi
le top du destructeur de documents la
caap et 750 fois chez moi qui va nous
dire qu'il est crevé salut les copains
en roumanie dont crever pourquoi il ya
quatre couverts annonce jules tu nous
refait le coup de la [ __ ]
moi je me casse c'est une surprise se
croise quelqu'un qu'on connaît classe de
seconde au lycée jeanne d'arc ou thé que
margot franchi cette porte ça dure match
au rugby à c'est la guerre ouais y'a
plus d'amitié qui tienne c'est chacun sa
gueule si ça se trouve c'est devenu un
coup bonjour